I've tested and used every single set of
airpods that Apple has ever released and
while they're currently selling four
different models the airpods 2 the 3es
the pro tws and the airpods max I can
tell you for sure which ones you want to
avoid buying for different use cases
whether you're buying them as a gift for
someone else or simply for yourself and
I know a lot of you guys are probably
thinking about waiting for the airpods 4
or the airpods Pro 3 but you probably
shouldn't because we just just got some
major leaks from Mark German the most
reliable Apple leaker out there and it's
not looking good but before I explain
when those are coming and what's the big
deal about them I want to go through
each set of airpods that Apple currently
sells and share my thoughts on how they
sound how much value you'll get out of
them and also how good of a gift they'll
be for somebody else starting off with
the airpods 2 this is the first pair
that I've ever purchased and they're
currently on sale for only 90 bucks on
Amazon which is actually crazy good and
you can still order them in time for
Christmas using the link below now these
are obviously the oldest pair out of the
lineup now being almost 5 years old
which means that the tech is now getting
a little bit outdated lacking a bunch of
the new features like spatial audio
adaptive EQ sweat and water resistance
and more they have the least amount of
battery life with 5 hours on the buds
and 24 hours total with the charging
case which does support wireless
charging but not with Max safe and even
though they're only 90 bucks I honestly
would not recommend these if you're
buying it for yourself or as a gift for
somebody else for a couple of different
reasons first of all they still use the
classic long stem design which is
getting a bit outdated making it obvious
that you have almost 5-year-old airpods
heading into
2024 especially with the double tap
design that isn't always reliable so
don't expect your gift recipient to be
too joyful about getting these since all
of the other airpods have the new short
stem design but if you're a baller on a
budget and you're getting these as a
gift for someone like your kids without
breaking the bank these are of course a
much better buy than some random pair of
bluetooth earbuds they're airpods so
they're still incredibly reliable in
terms of bluetooth pairing and all the
other software features that you get
with iOS however they honestly don't
sell that great especially compared to
many other options out on the market
right now with newer Tech and newer
speaker drivers they lack base and the
highs just aren't that clear and crisp
and turning them up to the max they get
very loud but they're just blaring into
your ears so you almost have to turn
them down to get better sound quality
they just don't sound great so you're
really just paying for the reliability
and for other people to see that you
have airpods in your ears now moving on
to the airpods 3 these ones are where
Apple worked some crazy magic because
unlike the airpods 2 they sound
incredible just as good as the original
airpods Pro but without the sealed in
ear tip design which is known to
increase the base reproduction they're
definitely a bit more pricey for 140
bucks on Amazon right now so they're a
bit more than 50% more expensive but I
would argue that they're definitely
worth the extra price espe especially if
you're buying them for yourself or as a
gift these ones come with a modern
looking case that supports Max safe
wireless charging and has up to a total
of 30 hours of battery life with 6 hours
for the buzz themselves and with the
short stem design they also have the
force touch sensor which you squeeze to
control your audio which works very very
well and these are the ones that you'd
want to be in your ears because of that
really nice new design and any gift
recipient would be more than happy to
get these due to the design alone
they're sweat and water resistant with
spatial audio adaptive EQ and more
reliable skin detect sensors for auto
pausing when you take them out of your
ears they're just a lot better overall
and the sound quality is incredible for
the price now beating out many other
options on the market at that price
point so these are a definite buy for
$140 on Amazon and now before I get into
the airpods pro two I first got to talk
about the airpods max these ones are
currently 450 bucks on Amazon so they're
$100 off which is the same price that I
bought my personal pair back in early
2022 a little over a year after their
initial release date at first these
things absolutely blew my mind with the
incredible sound quality and the very
wide and open Sound Stage which gave
them a very unique sound with Incredible
Bass the noise cancellation is also
topnotch beating out the best of the
competition like the ones from Sony
however I found that I didn't really use
them that often because first of all
they're much larger so you can't carry
them around everywhere like you can with
airpods that fit into your pocket so
they just weren't being used as much
they ended up just sitting on my
bookshelf for weeks at a time as I would
honestly forget about them which might
just be a personal problem but you've
got to admit that you have to be pretty
bold to walk around town or anywhere
else with these on your head unless
you're into that sort of thing compared
to the subtle airpods so to be
completely honest I would not recommend
these as a gift for others because first
of all they're crazy expensive and they
probably won't get as much use out of
them compared to a regular set of
airpods and even for personal use I
would not get these because they're now
3 years old and the tech is starting to
get outdated because they still have the
lightning connector for
$450 which is now being replaced with
USBC which is on the new iPhones they
still have Bluetooth 5.0 and they do not
support lossless audio using a cable but
the biggest problem happened when the
airpods Pro 2 came out so let's jump
into that I don't know how Apple did it
but they managed to make the airpods Pro
2 sound almost as good as the airpods
max in terms of sound quality yes the
Basse isn't as good as well as the Sound
Stage but they're almost there which
means that I don't really have much of a
reason to pick up my airpods Max anymore
the new airpods Pro 2 sound absolutely
incredible and surprisingly so much
better than the original airpods Pro
with very clear vocals highs and much
improved bass they're currently $60 off
on Amazon for the brand new USBC Port
model so they're about1 $90 which is
expensive but honestly such a great
discount that I would recommend anybody
looking at the aods 3 to spend the extra
50 bucks because these are much better
in every single way they use a sealed
ear tip design with different tip sizes
for the perfect seal giving you great
base reproduction and they also have
this special pressure release vent that
equalizes the pressure inside and
outside of your ears so you don't feel
like your ears are plugged all the time
and they have incredible noise
cancellation and transparency modes so
you can choose to hear people around you
or have it cancelled and it also comes
with the new adaptive audio mode which
filters loud sounds out automatically in
real time as well as conversation
awareness to switch modes automatically
these have the new H2 chip which is
extremely reliable with Bluetooth 5.3 to
match modern iPhones and the new airpods
Pro 2 case supports Max safe charging
and it comes with built-in speakers so
you can more easily find them when they
get lost these ones are hands down the
best ones to buy right now and well
worth the $190 on Amazon for the sound
quality which is so good they beat out
most of what's on the market right now
but also while getting all of the iOS
features which is their biggest
advantage over everything else and if
you're thinking about holding off for
the new airpods 4 or airpods Pro 3
models don't because according to Mark
Gman the fours aren't coming until the
end of
2024 alongside the airpods max 2 and the
airpods Pro 3s aren't coming until
20125 so there's really no point to wait
any longer to buy so with that said I'm
going to have links to each one of these
airpod sales in the description below
and if you enjoy this video you can
subscribe above and check out our airp
pods reviews right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video